des salariés triste et en colère depuis
ce matin ils sont une soixantaine à
bloquer lusine de champs sur yonne
jean pierre travaille ici depuis 37 ans
pour lui comme pour ses collègues
l'annnonce du plan social a été un coup
de massue on n'est plus beaucoup en tant
qu'ancien on est à peu près moins d'une
dizaine on est moins d'une dizaine
on a vécu trois dépôts de bilan déjà et
là on voit que ils veulent vraiment
fermé fermer la boîte pas en nous c'est
un gâchis parce que c'est une société
qui qui voilà qui sort du matériel quand
même exceptionnel
on travaille avec des gros clients comme
airbus alstom technip
voilà on a des gros clients comme ça
perdre ses compétences
ici c'est vraiment du gâchis quoi
spécialisée dans la fabrication de
matériels de transport
nicolas industrie emploie 113 salariés
sur ce site
72 d'entre eux sont aujourd'hui
concernés par le plan social la
direction met en avant les difficultés
financières d'ici là si c'était une papa
bien la société depuis quatre ans en
perte depuis 2014 la société a cumulé
près de 20 millions d'euros de pertes et
fait partie d'un groupe groupe allemand
qui lui aussi pour la deuxième année et
en l'étant pertes
la situation est effectivement
extrêmement critique pour ses sites
priorité selon la direction trouver un
repreneur
en cas d'échec les premières lettres de
licenciement seront envoyées fin février
pour les syndicats l'heure est à la
négociation des indemnités à l'heure
actuelle on a demandé 24 mois de salaire
moyen donc ce qui représente environ 50
55 mille euros on s'est quand même
enseigne et autre côté le groupe a quand
même de l'argent
ce conte il ya nicolas industries mais
aussi le groupe ont fait partir un
groupe allemand donc je pense que le
groupe allemand peut au moins faire ce
geste là des indemnités jugées trop
élevées par la direction les salariés
affirment qu'ils maintiendront le
blocage de l'usiné tant qu'un accord ne
sera pas trouvée